Janet Jackson steps out for the first  time since news broke that she's  expecting and only et has the pictures I  [Music]  thought it was important that you'd be  the first to know my husband and I are  planning our family that was Janet back  in April soon after ET broke the news  that she was pregnant but Janet hadn't  been spotted out since until this week  when paparazzi snapped the superstar  outside a big boutique back in action in  London Janet kept her baby bump but  mostly concealed behind a baggy black  sweater and a pair of grey sweatpants  but if you look closely you can make out  a bit of a bump  especially when you check out this  series of shots of the singer walking  and here's another view this time from  the side the 50 year old entertainer and  her husband businessman with samal mana  are expecting their first child before  the end of the year